welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders
from simply learned and today we're
gonna talk about how to increase Twitter
followers so welcome and let's get
started
so with Twitter it's all about tweets
it's actually a verb now when you do
something on Twitter you actually tweet
and there are a lot of people out there
tweeting in fact Twitter has over 1.3
billion accounts so a lot of tweets
going on in the world of Twitter so as
the third quarter in 2018 last year
Twitter had 326 million global monthly
active users
okay so active meeting every day using
the platform on a daily basis so a lot
of people using Twitter it's very easy
to use as you'll find out and what
you're gonna find out today is how to
increase followers on your Twitter
accounts so they can see more of your
tweets okay a little bit more about
Twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information being
disseminated across the platform so
tweets with videos so Twitter does a lot
of videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so if you watched our YouTube
videos and some of the other videos we
had out there regarding Facebook or
Instagram you'll know that videos do
perform better Twitter is no exception
so if you have a video even if it's done
on YouTube or even snot and published on
YouTube use it with Twitter you're gonna
get more engagement so Twitter has 75%
of its users use the platform for news
okay so people go to Twitter to get
their news that's where they go they
don't go to a regular website content
based website they get their news via
Twitter it's just very easy to digest
because it's so few characters 75% of
b2b businesses market on Twitter so not
only is a b2c or business-to-consumer
platform
it's a b2b bit
is to business platform so a lot of
businesses are on Twitter basically
promoting either a product service or
trying to establish themselves in the
industry using the platform so let's
take a look at Twitter and let's take a
look at some of the ways in which you
can increase your followers it all
starts with your profile you always want
to make sure you have a complete profile
your name obviously the Twitter platform
that you have is gonna have a handle
okay in this example here it's a totally
real person at totally real person is
the Twitter handle and that's what
you're going to want to use to
disseminate your Twitter profile to
others so you want to make sure that you
have a good image you have a real name
and a good handle that people can
associate with and remember so you want
to be able to set up this profile with a
key word friendly bio okay a link to
your website and a picture that
represents your brand always helps so
make sure it's complete you can even
take a step further by customizing the
color scheme of your profile you can add
a header image that sticks to your theme
that will help your profile stand out
and so let's take a look at an example
here so if I go to Twitter here if we go
to simply learn its Twitter account okay
there handle is simply at simply lower
okay and they've customized the header
they used their logo now if you're an
individual you probably want to use a
nice profile pic here where they're
based a little bit about them so just uh
you know customize complete profile goes
a long way you don't have to go
overboard with an elaborate design so to
speak but just make it stand out make it
associate with who you are as a person
and a brand it's always our best
practices and getting that profile up
and running you don't want to use
something bland and generic you know
take the extra step create something
unique make sure your profile is unique
you have a good image okay make sure
it's complete with you know telling
people who you are and what you're all
about that's really the first step on
really any social media platform so you
want to promote your Twitter profile to
drive users from other social media
platforms so when you actually get that
Twitter account setup and you actually
do have your hand off go ahead and share
it that's the first step in getting
followers if you're already on Facebook
if you're already on Instagram then use
those platforms to announce that you're
on Twitter you can also take that a step
further and you know send out an email
to friends or family or like I said if
you're on Facebook go ahead and set up a
post say hey guys I'm on Twitter
you know come follow me so you can also
use business cards advertisements
marketing materials and vents to put
that Twitter profile on okay so it
doesn't have to be within the social
media sphere it could be even on your
website it can be even in email so you
can basically promote that profile again
you want to make that profile that
handle easy to remember so totally real
person is the profile in this example
we're gonna use that profile every way
we can
whether that be offline or online you
don't don't be afraid to use it on a
business card especially if it's easy I
can just simply go to Twitter and type
in that handle so you want to stay
active on Twitter with regular retweets
replies and favorites and that's just
it's just so easy to retweet and reply
and add favorites so let's take a look
at that on Twitter so you could just
simply I'm logged in as me and if I want
to retweet something that simply learned
it I can just simply click on the
retweet button and I can add a comment
if I want to and then I'm going to
retweet that simple so now that tweet is
going to show up on my profile my handle
and I could simply like it if I scroll
down here okay top 10 IT trends shaping
2018 notice a simple tweet supported
with an image so I'm just gonna like
that so I can even comment on it I can
click on the comment and click a reply
here and that's gonna show up in this
tweet here just like if we click on this
I'll be able to see what other people
have written and so it's that simple if
I want I can just click on the email
button and see even send a message to
somebody right from that tweet the point
is I can do everything I need to do
right in the platform but to get started
if you don't have any tweets you know go
and find other
companies similar to you look at their
tweeting and you can always retreat that
that's a good way to get going with
tweets that's what I started doing when
I started on Twitter in 2008 I didn't
know what to write particularly and I
didn't know how to write it particularly
well so I looked at what other people
wrote and and tweeted and just retweeted
those that's a good way to get your
Twitter account started okay so engaging
with users is a great way to get more
followers so on simply learn i retweeted
one of their tweets I liked another one
of their tweets and it's probably gonna
get their attention somebody it's simply
learned it's gonna say okay Rob Sanders
went ahead and liked us and you know
what we're gonna go follow this guy he
seems to be somebody who's an audience
member who likes what we have to do
likes what we have to say like what
we're tweeting let's go ahead and follow
him and so that's a good way to get
going with your Twitter account is to
really start retweeting and liking other
tweets from other users so you can find
an appropriate time to post your tweets
to increase exposure retweets and
followers and you want to do this you
could do it within Twitter or as I
mentioned later you can do it in a
social media platform like sprout social
or HootSuite or later or buffer and
there's plenty of social media platforms
out there for you to schedule tweets
point is you want to be able to schedule
those tweets when it's the appropriate
time so you don't want to do it in the
middle of the evening because what's
gonna happen is likely by the morning
other tweets are going to bury your
tweet so you want to be able to find the
appropriate time to post your tweets so
according to a survey conducted by
HubSpot the best time to post is between
12:00 and 3:00 p.m. and why is that well
most people are usually on lunch check
in their phones yes Twitter has an app
in fact most people use the app just
like on Instagram just like on YouTube
the app is very popular on Twitter so
it's very easy for somebody to check
tweets especially during the lunch hour
and then for 5:00 to 6:00 p.m. that that
in-between time when when people are
wrapping up work or heading home okay so
weekdays have shown to have them
maximum amount of engagement so during
the week when people are working highly
engaged with whatever they're doing
depending on what industry you're in
they're likely going to check the
Twitter and react during those times
okay so that was a survey conducted by
hotspot but really what you want to do
is you want to be able to use one of
these social media platforms like a
HootSuite or later and find out exactly
when are people engaging with your
tweets when a what time of the day what
day of the week are you getting the most
retweets or the most likes okay that's
what you want to do so you can use this
as a starting point as a best practice
but eventually you're gonna have to
cater to your audience based on when
you're getting your tweets engaged so
you want to increase followers by
following more people it's that simple
and so it really is that simple I'm
going to rephrase that so it really is
that simple so if I go back to Twitter
you know Twitter is always going to
recommend somebody for me to follow and
normally those are people that are
similar as myself okay so they're not
just gonna choose random people they're
gonna choose people who are following
people you're following so there's gonna
be connection to some degree or they
could be people who use similar hashtags
tweeting the same content so you want to
go ahead and follow people the rule of
thumb on Twitter is if you follow
somebody on Twitter chances are they're
gonna follow you back you know I was
once told when I was using Twitter that
hey you want to give somebody about
three days to follow you back so that's
always what the rule I stuck to you know
wait about three days start following
people you can see here 833 people that
or accounts Twitter accounts that simply
learns following in over ten thousand
nine hundred followers to simply learns
Twitter account so for me I don't mind
having a nice balance myself I have just
as many followers as I do following and
that's a good thing so because you want
to be able to keep up with what people
are tweeting and so you can retweet at
the same time you want to be following
people as well because they're gonna
follow you back okay and
how you can build up your Twitter
followers by following people and it's
as simple as clicking on a file link so
the key here is to follow people who
follow your content people who are
followers of your followers and you can
use Twitter's who to follow list and
upload your email contacts to Twitter
okay since they know you they're more
likely to follow you back okay so you
can use Twitter's who to follow a list
and so if we go back to Twitter here's
the who to follow list and so this is
what Twitter is gonna recommend but you
can click on this link here find people
you know okay so if I click on find
people I know then I can upload my
contacts from Outlook or Gmail and
they're gonna find people who are
already on Twitter based on who I'm
connected with so generally that's how
it works that's a quick way to get more
followers just to connect with people
you know
by the way I'm gonna follow simply learn
because I wasn't following them prior so
now I just clicked on the follow button
now I am following so now I'm gonna see
simply learns tweets in my feed so let's
take a second to look at a brand okay so
it's time for a brand watch let's have a
look at some of the best tweets of 2018
now remember there are a lot of active
users millions of active users that's a
lot of tweets so what we did we scoured
Twitter from 2018 and we went ahead and
picked out some tweets that we thought
were pretty good and so the first one is
Wendy's now I don't know if any of you
have actually eaten it Wendy's I used to
eat it Wendy's awhile ago I know there
Frosty's are pretty good so what they've
done is they incorporated that frosty as
part of a giveaway okay so basically
they're saying hey grab yourself a free
frosty with a purchase in our app so
they're encouraging people to use our
app and then they're following that up
by saying hey and then join us on Twitch
from 2 to 5 Eastern as we unlock all
that frosty goodness so they're
promoting something that's the one
happened on a specific point in time
this is a last January they're
encouraging people to use their app and
you're using that frosty as
kind of a carrot if you will okay is a
catch it's a giveaway so they were able
to you know basically wrap a bunch of
things into one so get encourage people
to take part and I'm sure a lot of
people went ahead and took part of this
but we could definitely see that 206
retweeted this tweet 302 basically
commented on it and over 3,000 liked the
tweet so the tweet was good and it
basically engaged with users who doesn't
like a free giveaway especially free
frosting so that's why this particular
tweet really does some justice for the
target audience there audience there
they're giving something away to their
audience just by allowing them to you
know user out okay so this tweet
combines a lot into one and I like it
apparently a lot more people than I did
three thousand plus also like this tweet
and so moving on to how to increase your
followers on Twitter you want to mention
other people in your tweets to increase
engagement so what do we mean by that so
let's look at Twitter so go back if we
look at simply learn just take a look at
some of their tweets what they're doing
if we scroll down here they have
hashtags so they are mentioning specific
hashtags but you can also mention
handles as well so the hashtag is always
gonna start with either pound sign but
if we scroll down here use the @ symbol
you're actually mentioning some money so
in this case we're mentioning Matt
Bailey so Matt Bailey says is Matt
Bailey's handle and so if you get a
shout out to somebody they're gonna pick
up on that and then they're going to
probably follow you okay who doesn't
appreciate getting recognized for
something especially something as small
as a tweet okay notice I can go ahead
and click follow if I want to follow my
Bailey but it's not a bad idea to add
people into your tweet and you simply do
that by just using the @ symbol and
using their Twitter handle it's a good
way to get recognized by that Twitter
follower it also increases engagement
because it's adding validity to the
tweet and it definitely catches the
attention of the person mentioned
member if you use that person's handle
they're going to see that that you
mention them okay and what it's likely
gonna do is start some type of Twitter
relationship okay they're gonna then
follow you you're gonna follow them and
chances of them retweeting you in the
future or mentioning you in the future
is probably going to increase and
overall that increases engagement so
another important thing you want to do
is find and use hashtags that are
relevant to your brand and audience so
this is a must this is a mandatory on
Twitter you need to use hashtags
Twitter's all about hashtags and every
tweet that goes out should have a
hashtag okay and so what you can do is
figure out what hashtags are trending so
here what Twitter does they trends for
you so these are all specific hashtags
that are trending it's Mother's Day and
happy mother hey Sunday morning whatever
works for you these are trends that
happen to be moving meaning a lot of
people are using them clicking on them
okay so you can use a popular hashtag
what I would also recommend is you use a
unique hashtag the rule of thumb is
usually about two hashtags in a tweet
but that's a rule of thumb but rules are
made to be broken do what's best for you
if you want to include more than two
hashtags go for it the only thing I'm
recommending is include a hashtag so
find out what's trending you could just
look right in Twitter or you could just
create your own unique hashtag it works
both ways
but when you have a hashtag in your
tweet and somebody clicks on it then
they're going to go to that particular
handle that hashtag and so when they
look at the hash they're gonna see all
the tweets with that hashtag in it so
that's the idea behind hashtags you want
to have hashtags okay so if somebody
clicks on a hashtag that you used then
they're likely going to see your tweet
in that hashtags feed okay so that's how
hashtags work you want to use hashtags
okay but you want to use hashtags that
are relevant to your brand and audience
that's really the key so hashtags help
your tweets to be found through Twitter
search that's improving your reach and
increase the visibility of your post so
that's another benefit twitter has
search functionality so somebody can
simply go in and start searching on
Twitter so if I go back to Twitter I can
just do a hashtag and start typing in
something like Spanish and I'm gonna get
some of the most popular Spanish
hashtags
we're hashtags with the word Spanish in
it and so this is an idea for me that if
I wanted to use a hashtag with Spanish
in it these are some ideas but they're
certainly searchable on Twitter okay so
if I just click on Spanish I'm gonna be
able to see all the hashtags with the
word Spanish in the hashtag so
definitely use hashtags it's the most
beneficial feature of Twitter bar none
so some reasons why using hashtags is
also a good idea well you're gonna get
more engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your tweets and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on Twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team in the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know I work we simply learn but you know
simply learn has a good Twitter account
you know they have lots of followers
they're doing a lot of tweeting so if I
wanted to be just like simply learn well
I could simply just go to their Twitter
account and see what they're doing okay
see what they're using as hashtags so
what kind of tweets they're implementing
and see who's following them so I can
simply just click on the ten thousand
nine hundred followers that they have
and what I could do is I can go through
and start following the people that are
following them so just mimic your
competition to some degree or mimic
others in the end
you know look at what they're tweeting
again start out by retweeting some of
the stuff they're retweeting if it's
good stuff if it's a good tweet don't be
afraid to retweet even your competitors
tweets okay use unique hashtags use the
hashtags they're using look at who's
following their brand so you can really
learn a lot from brothers in your
industry including your competition
because what works for them again might
work for you especially when it comes to
hashtags or people who's following them
again people who are following them
would likely follow you if you're in the
same industry so it's as simple as
looking at who's following them and
following those same people remember the
rule of thumb is if you're following
somebody they're likely to follow you
back so again you can analyze things
like the number of followers they have
the frequency of their tweets what their
profile looks like how they respond to
the competition of customers okay what
are they treating about what types of
content brings them more engagement
meaning of all the tweets which one is
getting the most likes or retweets it's
some sense of what they're doing and
again when I say mimic I mean wearing
what I'm saying is best practices from
that Twitter account this will give you
an idea what you need to do to get more
followers so it's always a good form of
flattery when you can mimic what
somebody else is doing just like every
other social media platform following
Twitter influencers who belong in your
industry is always a good idea so if
you're in the food industry and there's
these star chefs out there probably not
a bad idea to follow those star chefs
you know if you're in the technology
industry well probably not a bad idea to
you know follow Bill Gates or Elon Musk
or Richard Branson or somebody else and
that's a big influencer has an influence
on a lot of people okay but make sure
they're in your industry that's the key
if you can make sure they're in your
industry when you follow them chances
are if they look at your Twitter account
and see your posting or maybe retweeting
some of their tweets they're likely to
follow you and if they're following you
your tweets are gonna show up on their
handle on their feet and so don't be
afraid to go out and connect and follow
those influencers it's a good way to
boost up your followers so in this I'll
help you gain follower
since you can replicate what they've
done with their profile so again just
like the competition mimic what your
influencers are doing okay so people
tend to follow people who follow
influencers so you're all of one like
mind so to speak
okay influencers might retweet or share
your post if they find you treat
retweeting favorites and replying to
their post so remember if you follow in
a retweet er or excuse me an influencer
and you retweet their post chances are
they might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from simply learned
so if I click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that Matt Bailey was at so it was a
retweet from Matt Bailey as a matter of
fact but you could see what simply
learns doing is there including either a
video or there including an image in
every tweet and so that's likely to
boost up engagement so according to
buffer which is a another social media
platform adding a relevant high quality
image in your tweets can help you gain
more than a hundred fifty percent
engagement videos are six times more
likely to be retweeted so if you have an
arsenal video or even one video don't be
afraid to use it
my recommendation is trying to use
images as much as you can almost every
tweet images go a long way and again
it's going to help improve engagement
meaning more retweets more followers
okay more followers more eyeballs so as
a snowball effect just by using images
okay so let's take a look at another
brand from 2018 okay pizza always my
good example
to use on these webinars I like pizza
here this just says it all you know
they're talking about art and they're
using pizza in the form of art so they
didn't really have to say much else here
this pretty much says it all
and they did get some retweets they get
some some likes so sometimes you don't
have to say a lot to make your point
sometimes just the image itself will do
the job this was actually not from 2018
this goes all the way back to 2016 so it
still holds true if you use an image
that image is going to get engagement
okay so on Twitter just like most other
social media platforms you can promote
your tweet so you can use Twitter ads to
do that so you can promote your tweet
and what you do by promoting it is
putting it up above so that most people
will be able to see it okay so see if we
can find an example if I go here I can
see this person is promoting their
handle but if I go down here I can see a
promoted tweet by Constant Contact so
they're promoting their tweet here so
it's not a bad idea if you have some
media budget to go ahead and either
promote your tweet or advertise on
Twitter so what that's going to do is
put you any more prominent position and
get your tweets out there and the whole
idea for that is to get people to engage
here you can see a call to action from
Constant Contact so if I click on that
I'm gonna go to probably a landing page
on their website and so the whole idea
when you advertise on Twitter is really
just like any other social media
platform you want to put yourself in
front of the right audience and so
Twitter's no exception
so with Twitter you could put yourself
in front of the right audience so what
you could do is you could promote a
tweet you know do promoted trends or you
could do promoted accounts so you have a
number of different advertising options
on Twitter what we just looked at was
you know looking at promoted accounts
and a promoted tweet so when you do
advertise there are advantages you have
to pay only after achieving your
marketing objective so that's a benefit
of Twitter the cost per click it's a
cost per click model so it
tends to be fairly low you could tell
your audience so again you're picking
and choosing who you want your Promoted
Tweet or trend or account to be in front
of its targeting is based on either
engagement or it's based on keywords ie
hashtags so really you can tailor who
you want your tweet or your handle to be
in front of and so that's the really the
benefit of Twitter if you have a lot of
active users on Twitter you can really
put yourself in front of those active
users if the your relevant audience at a
low cost per click so it's definitely
worth the test so you want to offer
Twitter support to your users ok so I
can't stress this enough ok so what you
want to do is when users have questions
about your product they're more likely
to tweet you for support hence they're
likely to file your account so don't be
afraid to use the messaging option as
well so we go back to Twitter ok chances
are somebody might have a question for
you here you could look at big ads it's
great connecting with PPC experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is you're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
in the form of customer service so don't
be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy Twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your Twitter
follow account these bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying of Twitter
followers you want to build your Twitter
following naturally Twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of bot accounts that were paid to follow
users were shuts down shut down by
Twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of ok if you want to
pay for something pay for promoted tweet
reach out to influencers look at what
your competition is doing use hashtags
okay these are all best practices and
organic ways to build followers so don't
get involved with anything that's going
to involve BOTS and adding thousands of
followers to Twitter account because
chances are it's just going to lead to
no engagement so create useful and
relevant content so what we started out
by saying is hey if you're not sure what
to do
retweet retweet what somebody else is
doing you know look at your
competition's Twitter account see what
they're tweeting get some ideas as to
what you want to tweet so you want it to
be useful and relevant to your industry
you want somebody to engage that's the
whole idea behind Twitter the whole idea
is if you're gonna tweet something you
want to get somebody to engage with it
so use Twitter pose your old recent blog
post brand news industry news and events
and highlight customer stories I mean
all of those or ideas that you can do to
put content out there okay so for me one
of the things I do when I'm definitely
one for industry news so if I'm in the
industry of digital marketing if Google
did a recent algorithm update I'm going
to likely tweet about it
or retweet it I also am a blogger so on
my particular website if I blog I'm
gonna make sure that blog gets over to
Twitter so those are some ideas in which
you can create useful and relevant
content on your Twitter account you
definitely want to get that content out
there but you want to make it reusable
and relevant quality over quantity
because you want people to engage so
bring variety to the type of content you
share so I'm in digital marketing I deal
with pay-per-click SEO but am I gonna
just do pay-per-click and SEO know I
know that analytics I know that you know
Google tag manager I know that a/b
testing all of those are elements of
digital marketing so I'm gonna branch
out and talk about some of those things
that support digital marketing so that's
an example of bringing a variety to the
type of content you share so don't just
stick to one thing you know feel free to
reach out a little bit shake things out
by sharing other forms of updates like
engaging quotes and questions these work
best when complimented by an image and
an act as a great discussion starter so
good point here even if you want to
branch out of your industry and just
throw in a nice useful quote it's always
a good way to gain
some attention and get some engagement
okay let's look at another brand and see
what they've tweeted about so we're
looking at Forester here so think about
emotional qualities and their
implications so here you can see
customers that feel surprised we're
grateful or appreciated they're sharing
that insight with you and so this was
interesting when I saw this so what I
did was I simply you see the hashtag
here for digital basically if you want
to look at this particular study
I just went to Twitter and I typed in
that hashtag and now I'm gonna be able
to see you know some of the other
studies that they've done here you can
see top 10 I teach runs shaped be in
2019 so I'm just following the Twitter
handle that they used so Forrester does
a lot of good research a lot of good
insights and so what they've done here
that makes this tweet look so good is
they've actually put an image of the
results in the tweet so they used an
image to help gain engagement or
increase engagement notice they also
gave a shout-out to somebody as well as
use some good hash tagging so good tweet
this was back in 2016 but again a good
use of the image with the tweet so you
want to organize tweet chats to interact
with your users and bring in new
followers so you know you basically want
to be organized when you're dealing with
what chats so tweet chats and able you
send out tweets on a particular topic
using a designated hashtag so during a
certain time to interact with your
followers and other users so you could
do it at a specific time to really get
out a specific topic but you want to be
able to stay organized so that you know
you what you're chatting about is
reaching the right audience and you're
getting the right following and the
right engagement okay you can also pin
your best updates and tweets to your
profile so you can just use that pin and
what that's going to do is pin it to the
top and keep it there so that you know
people who go to your Twitter handle are
gonna be able to see that best tweet
that you've done so what you want to do
here is use the one that's most engaging
so pinning your best update or tweet
meaning the one that's really had a lot
of engagement
meaning retweets and followers and likes
you want to do that you want to pin that
to your profile and that will enable
first-time visitors to see it and if
they can see something that other people
engaged within that's gonna encourage
them to share and probably follow you so
and and that's always what you want to
do you always want to put your best foot
forward so pin your best tweet to your
profile so I mentioned this earlier use
tools to schedule when to publish your
tweets so here's some of the most
popular platforms you know I use sprout
social so if we take a look at sprout
social here I'm in sprout social I'm
connected to my Twitter account I can
simply just start tweeting about
something here so you can see it's gonna
let me know how many characters I have
remaining so to 880 to start out with
when I'm done tweeting notice I can add
an emoji I can upload media I can tag a
specific location okay I can even you
know call out a specific Twitter profile
now I can schedule this myself or I can
use the schedule below I can pick and
choose a time to schedule the tweet now
again you want to be able to use the
sprout social whatever social media tool
you're using to figure out when the best
time of day and the day of the week to
actually tweet when are you getting the
best engagement so ideally that's what
you want to do you want to tweet when
you're likely to get the best engagement
when those eyeballs are actually gonna
look at that tweet okay but you also
want to separate out your tweets so
they're not on one on top of another
because if you actually tweet
back-to-back then those tweets are just
gonna get buried so if you spread them
out a little bit then you're likely to
maximize your number of impressions or
eyeballs on that tweet so if you
schedule a tweet multiple tweets in the
same day then post them a few hours
apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always gonna get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you and not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just sprout
social HootSuite buffer oh they'll help
you determine the exact
time your audience is most active and
schedule post to increase attraction so
you know most of these social media
platforms did the same thing so really
what you want to do is you really want
to nail down that exact time your
audience is gonna be most active okay
that's the whole idea behind using it
and when you actually do tweet you are
gonna get results and these social media
platforms are gonna share those results
with you and then when you understand
based on your audience behavior when
they're engaged when they're not
engaging that's when you're going to
fine-tune your scheduling so what you
also want to do as you're doing these
tweets as we looked at earlier of
Wendy's is run contests or giveaways
remember Wendy's gave away that free
frosty you don't be afraid to give away
something if it means more engagement
more eyeballs which could lead to
basically future customers so contests
can help increase your reach and
exposure and each new participant can be
considered as a potential follower so it
also gives your followers an opportunity
to tag their friends who would be
interest and participating so really
come up this is a great way to be
creative come up with a good idea to get
your your audience involved because
what's likely gonna happen as your
audience is going to share this contest
with others
that aren't following you and so what's
going to happen is when they share it
you're gonna get more followers you're
gonna get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
Twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that it's very simple
but when you do then people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if I just go to my website here if I
scroll down we actually have your
Twitter embedded on our website as well
because we want you know people to see
what we're tweeting about and you can
see I just retweeted the simply learn
tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
on my feet here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what I retweeted and that's
gonna help simply learn out because
simply learn is likely even get some
clicks on this particular tweet from my
website so it's also a good way to keep
your website fresh and updated because
if you're an active Twitter user and
you're tweeting a lot
then hey that's gonna show up on your
website and it's gonna show that hey
you're fresh you're engaging you keep up
to date it's just gonna make it look
good and make your website feel fresh
and not stale so embedding your Twitter
updates will help you add new followers
as well because it's people who are
coming to your website that may not even
know you have a Twitter account so you
can also do this in a blog post and a
newsletter and other forms of
communication media so it doesn't
necessarily have to be just your website
but I would definitely recommend it
because it will give a boost to your
Twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention when this is from PlayStation
so PlayStation is matching hey we got a
multi view on Apple TV today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have a
Playstation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically said hey look what
happened to us today you know check out
this new feature that got supported on
Apple TV so you never know what's gonna
happen with a tweet when you tweet good
things are likely gonna happen whether
that be somebody liking it retweeting it
or somebody adding you as a follower
something's good is going to come out of
tweeting Twitter is an easy platform to
use and if you take into account all
these best practices you are going to
increase your Twitter followers so I
want to thank you again for hanging in
there if you guys have any suggestions
about some other best practices on how
to increase your Twitter followers then
feel free to you know add them to the
comments section below this video
otherwise thank you again if you need
more information please go to simply
learn com thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here